and what happened in 2017 was a
very big fire shepherds saw
surrounded by volume without being able to go out or
anyone to come in to help us and
here it fell happier more in
backyards my feeling was that helping me
all burnt
today was the worst day for
me  I think that between 60 and 70
people died in the area
andthen
the restaurant number the immediate damage
was like this I was like everything matte the
cement with the strong heat scales all
over the establishment
is its neighbors the customers demand
to have it operated again and I said  no,
but be careful if this is not the case, I'm not going to
insist on studying, they were plastering the
walls, it was me when I found myself with everything
damaged and without having the possibility of
recovering with my capital and I'm
desperate neuropediatrician asked me to
help me with 47 thousand books
and nobody forgets  the misfortune those who
continue to live would improve life
we ​​are rebuilding the